All right, thank you very much. All right. This is my story.
I was dating this girl, like, two years
ago. I'd been dating her for, like, eight months, and she wanted to meet my parents. She was really give me shit
like, "how come I haven't met your parents?".
And uh, you know, I
always just - I never, liked - you know, I never brought anybody home to meet my parents. I was like 30 years
old. Never met - brought anybody
home. Never - I didn't ever like meeting people in general. [LAUGHTER]
I didn't want to meet her parents. I always hate it when you had to meet, like - you know, go out with somebody you have to, like, meet
their friends and shit. You know, sitting at the table
trying to be interesting. I usually end up just sitting there staring at my  mashed potatoes or some shit.
So she's like, you know, "how come - what's wrong with you?".
You know, "How come you don't want to meet me," you know,
bring me home to meet your parents? I started thinking about it. Like, you know, not only had I never brought
anybody home - you know, a girl home - and I was 30 years old - I never brought anybody
home - even, like, back in, like, first grade,
Like second grade I mean I had friends and shit I just never brought him home.
So I started thinking, like, you know, how the hell did that start? You know? So basically
So we're basically driving up from New York to go to my house to finally, um, meet my parents. And
uh, I remember, like, I think it was like when I was in first grade. We used to have a bus
right out front of my house, and my parents used to always be arguing. And my dad was like
a maniac, you know. Always screaming "God damn fucking bitch!". You know?
Just total psycho. My dad was like a complete psychopath.
You know? Like his nickname in my house was called The Thing. Because that's what he was,
fucking thing, that, like, if he wasn't around, we'd say "Dude, is the Thing home?". You know, like,
if he wasn't home, we could chill.
He was just, like, never in a good mood. So one day I'm down at the bus stop, there's like, you know, ten other kids down there
and shit. And we're all, like, in first grade, second grade,
third grade, waiting for the bus. And it's, like, towards the summertime, so my parents got like the windows open and shit.
So I can start to hear, like, an argument start, like, "well what the fuck do you mean..."
And I'm sitting there going "please, please let the bus come, please"
"Please please, let the bus come, please, for Christ sake" and all the sudden, "YOU GODDAMN FUCKING BITCH!
Bleh bleh! Screamin and shit
and I remember just looking at all the other kids' looks on their faces like, I guess, you know,
so most kids never even heard curses. So they couldn't believe it
couldn't believe it and I was just -- that's when it really
that man, my family's really, really screwed up.
And, uh, I started going over other kids' houses and their parents seemed to get
along, and they were like cool. And, uh, so the whole time I'm driving back
back and my girlfriend coming up, all this stuff was like coming back, and I'm thinkin.
and I really like all like like I'm a six year old kid again like getting all nervous. Like how my
dad is going to like act
'cause it's like embarrassing. You know, I mean.
And I remember like like he was one of these dues where like, uh, I don't know, he was always in a bad mood
like he'd try to like teach you something he'd say it once.
And then when you didn't get it he'd just say it louder and
louder. And I remember at six going this guy, he's retarded. Like, I remember
We got a dog and he's trying to teach this dog how to sit. All right. It's a dog
it doesn't speak English and he's sitting there goin' to the thing, he's like going to the thing like,
alright, "Sit." to this little puppy, "Sit!"
"SIT DOWN. YOU'RE GOING TO GET OVER THERE AND YOU'RE GONNA SIT DOWN!"
Dog's sitting there, like, walking around like peeing like "what the fuck is wrong with this guy?"
And that was, like, his thing, man.Everything, like, in my house, my parents, they were like were ridiculously strict.
They had all these stupid rules, like I remember they had like this one rule whatever you didn't eat for dinner, They would just like wrap
it in cellophane and you had to like eat it the next morning for breakfast.
And it's like everybody's sitting eating their, like, pancakes and waffles and you're like
eating cube steaks and shit.
Dad would be going,
Come on, EAT IT! I don't want to eat it. EAT IT.
So I'm like, driving back and that's all I'm thinking is like, aw, this guy is going to completely embarrass me
and, uh, I don't know, like, it's just I just felt
weird, like my family was like, like the -- you know those families that loving, like
build somebody up. Like our family just always just like ripping somebody down
like uh I think the worst thing he ever
did to me. This is the want to really kind of made me like the anxious, worrysome
person that I am, you know, uh, it was right around Christmas, and I was already thinking this
because I was driving this girl up for Christmas. He, uh,
He was giving me shit one day, he always
hated when I was joking around. I think making my mother laugh, somehow I don't knoe bug him or whatever
So he kept giving me shit, "Come on man you know. You keep joking around, you know
Giggling all the time -- you're acting like a little girl." and I'm thinking, like,
And I'm thinking like -- because he's always fucking with me -- Oh, God, here's a new angle. You know, you ask him for a football for Christmas
act like a little girl? What the fuck's wrong with you?" And I'm just sitting there like, oh Jesus. So, like, two weeks later,
So like two weeks later, it's Christmas time. I've got like four brothers, right? We always sneak down
o go look at the presents. So we go downstairs, right? There's all these gifts down there
all wrapped and we're all looking to see who got what you know. There's all these little tags, like, "To: Ed, From: Santa."
Santa." [clears throat]
You know. Be like "To Bob
"To: Bob, From: Mom and Dad." Or whatever. And I'm sitting there
Phew. Just wait a second.
[Breathing]
So I look
In like, the middle of
the tree, I see there's a doll
And I'm thinking, I got four brothers what the fuck is there a doll
sitting here? And I remember just
looking at this thing. Do you ever see those Spike Lee movies were, like, the
like the background moves and the character doesn't?
It was like one of those deals.
And I look up at this doll, right? And it says, "To: Bill, From: Santa."
Santa"
And I'm like, "what the fuck?" Guy
got me a goddamn doll. He came downstairs and he's laughing and shit and he's making me take a picture and I'm like
six years old and I'm crying and stuff, and uh,
and I'm thinking of this shit as I'm pulling up into the driveway, and
I'm like freaking out because I'm finally going to bring somebody home to meet
this fuckin maniac.
And, uh, I'm telling her you know, "I don't know how this guy's gonna
So we walk into the house and it's like
you know, It's like, uh,
Candles and shit. You know Christmas tree, it's all real nice,
dim lights and stuff. She comes in she meets my dad, and the
dude is like totally normal. After me
building this guy up the whole ride back. He's like fuckin like, you know that dude from Leave It
to Beaver. He's like the nicest guy ever.
He's all cordial. And I
remember, I'm just getting like pissed at the guy, going, why isn't he being a
dick?
And she's sitting there, like, taking me aside, going, he's the greatest
guy and I can't believe you were saying all that stuff, he's such, he's you know, smart, he's intelligent,
he's so interested
in what I have to say. And I remember, I was like, I was
like so pissed at the guy.
I mean I really hated him when I was growing up to the point of one time. He went on
the driveway and he's running out to his car. And he slipped and fell and broke his shoulder
And at that point me and my brothers so fuckin' hated this guy, when he came to the house and mom was like taking care of him,
we snuck out the back
door to look at his footprints in the snow, to see where he slipped and fell, and I'm telling you
we were laughing our asses off at this guy.
"Right there, right there, that's where... Fuck! Why couldn't I have seen that?"
So, uh
So uh, he ended up being
like the sweetest guy ever and there was nothing anxious about it. I like worried about it for like, I don't know,
From the beginning of time dating girls, like fifteen, and I just ended up feeling really stupid.
And, uh, I was kind of pissed I was just looking at the guy, going
Why the fuck couldn't you have been
like this you know twenty years ago when I needed him to be like that
that rather than you know
being the way he was? And, uh,
that's my story. Thanks.
Thank you.